welcome to this video yeah let's play
you form for a change under at least I
get some main line type of opening I'm
not a scary maybe not something yeah
this line is some interesting I have
tried them in this some recent
tournament I played in in Austria with
some success it's um it's an interesting
way to play maybe this was bad roop d1
sarani yeah if I take yeah this was bad
if I take and play d4 it's got Bishop g4
a bit bit annoying ok maybe takes with
the night ok thanks it's not now
terrible for black bottom after the porn
capture look I think was a bit misplaced
yeah this no is the kind of position you
Ava aren't hurt oh no no draw we just
started the game so i can i can play see
for my D 5 year isn't this just winning
material no okay we can move the night
now takes takes gras Alfred one of those
idiots sorry you have some guys
constantly offering draws for no
particular reason usually a very awful
positions and it's completely pointless
okay so d6 would be nice but let's
complete development Bishop fyd six
would win the bishop would be a very
nice of course
first 93 and now g6 some as a threat
okay now this is some still quite ok the
night on da de Sun is really misplaced I
didn't play it in the most precise menem
i guess but so should be it should be
quite good
okay I thought you would take a dig be
tuned to at least have have a pawn for
this for this bad position but didn't do
that draw Alfred yeah of course now the
play is simply based on the fact that
he's got this this awful night ok G 45
and 90 force is so the way to go on
something else grah are fake yeah some
people just have the idea to to make a
complete ass out of themselves in front
of like thousand to us I mean why not
got nothing better to do can just four
draws all along with video so one way to
spend your on your day okay so 94 this
was the idea at least and now d 6 would
be the normal way to continue that now
maybe this wasn't the best way to play I
don't know
No
probably I should have done done this
differently you need to be forceful and
push push here form for the deep own but
now this sexy ass rookie form a waiter
can take take this and not him sorry
Rocky Fork winner for is still ok forgot
about be 79 so I need to need to do that
came Queen B 5 taking them the night
complicated and unfortunately I'm rather
low on time
he goes rock d 7 i'm not quite sure what
I'm doing just simple move maybe a five
or something i but i don't know i don't
really have a clear-cut continuation
look 27 Quincy six justjust rope the
eight problem okay I don't want to spend
lots of time him okay this is simply not
working maybe I didn't see 95 so as
possible be 7 9 p-7 would be would be a
bit embarrassing okay me too best would
be to get the colors of him okay
and then be 7 next maybe I should've
played kranji form I wonder why isn't he
offering a couple of more drawers this
would be a would be interesting Rock d5
I could've played actually instead of
before yeah but ok the position is
pretty pretty ugly for black anyway this
also just be seven threatened maybe here
somehow disarranged his windows him and
doesn't find the draw button anymore
this would be very irritating for him I
guess ok so just taking a drug tier 4
and win with the B porn at the end
should be good good continuation night a
six and b8 queen it's pretty difficult
to avoid all that so first this one to
kill off the night so that 97 is not
possible and then look ahead next move
now I can actually do that Oh take it
what is the most precise
this one actually want to keep the beep
on
check
black resigned John it's bad young if
all you are able to do is suffer draw
all the time yeah but I didn't really
refute it 22 nicely I mean this was
maybe I'm here maybe Bishop f4 is so
badgam yeah I'm probably Bishop f4 is
better i don't know i mean this is bad
for black but it's not it's not
completely completely over the the whole
problem is always this the stat night on
98 he meets to spend lots of time to get
it back into play and I'm not sure at
all about this this was this was right
but then it was son it looked at looked
dangerous in factory a black can take I
didn't see that 96 Andrew p6 this is
nice yeah this is the C could have done
after this I'm probably probably a in
good fashion again in good shape again
yeah mtm their various ways rookie voice
is good but I think white is always
winning with the beep on it's it's too
much supported by the bishop and and the
active look alright thanks for watching